لقد خفّض صندوق النقد الدولي توقعاته للنمو
إلى 3.5٪ ليس انخفاضًا كبيرًا ،
لكن العديد من العجائب التي تغذي
الطلب على النفط مباشرةً وفي بعض أكبر
عملائك ، وكذلك ما تراه حتى
الآن من حيث استمرار الطلب
لا نرى أي شيء  التأثير على الطلب على النفط حتى
الآن في الصين وخاصة أننا نشهد
نموًا أهمية حوالي مليوني
برميل نشهد المزيد من الاستيراد
من أرامكو السعودية شهريًا
ولا يؤثر علينا حتى IE i
من حيث التوقعات التي ننظر إليها  1.4
إلى 1.5 مليون برميل يوميًا لعام 2018 ،
فأنت واثق من أنني أستطيع تحمل
هذا النمو القوي جدًا للطلب اليومي
جيدًا ، فهو
مشابه تقريبًا للعام الماضي إذا نظرت في
العام الماضي إلى 1.3 إلى 1.4 في سوريا التي تتحدث
عنها  1.4 إلى 1.5 لذلك ليس
ضمن التوقعات التي كنا
نتوقعها عندما تحدثت إليكم في
دافوس 2018 ، كنا نبحث عن الاكتتاب العام
وكان هذا هو التوجيه الذي حصلنا عليه
من ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان الآن
نقترح  ربما يكون عام 2021
واقعيًا ومفيدًا حقيقيًا من قيامك
بذلك أم أنه بصفتك الرئيس التنفيذي المسؤول
عن تحمل هذا الاكتتاب ، ما هي الفائدة الحقيقية التي
أعتقد أنك على حق تمامًا
نتحدث عنها عام 2021 والآن بالنسبة للاكتتاب العام
كانت الخطة  تحولت في الأصل لعام 2018
بسبب أرامكو السعودية خطة
للاستحواذ على 70 في المائة
من أسهم الخدمات التي تخضع
لصندوق الاستثمار العام والتي ستستغرق بعض
الأوقات بعد أن نتفق
مع صندوق الاستثمار العام
هناك متطلبات مكافحة الاحتكار  متطلبات الجهات الرقابية
التي ستأخذنا خلال عام
2019 ومن ثم عليك التفكير
في ميزانياتك بنتائج تلك
الصفقة والتكامل الذي يحدث
بعد ذلك لمدة عام على الأقل قبل
أن تتمكن من السماح لأرامكو السعودية إذا
كنت رجل مراهنة تقول  2021
تريد أن تفعل ذلك وهل يمكنك الإجابة على
السؤال هل هو عبء عليك أم هل
ترى فائدة حقيقية من طرحه للجمهور على
الإطلاق إنه ليس عبئًا لأننا
كنا مستعدين لحسن الحظ كما تعلمون لدينا
قمنا بجميع الأعمال ، أحدها هناك
تدقيق مع إعداد الاحتياطي الذي
يأتي بعد
أن أصبحت الشركة شركة مساهمة
اعتبارًا من يناير 2018 تم تغيير النظام المالي ،
وتم تغيير جميع العناصر المطلوبة
لإدراج أرامكو إما من
قبل الحكومة أو من قبل الشركة  لذلك
نحن جاهزون لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى إكمال
عملية الاستحواذ والمضي قدمًا في إجراءات
مكافحة الاحتكار والجهة التنظيمية ، ثم
عكس ذلك في ميزانياتنا
العمومية قبل أن نذهب ، يمكننا الإعلان عن
جميع العناصر المطلوبة من قبل
المنظمين لإدراج أرامكو السعودية  لقد
أجرينا تدقيقًا مستقلاً يوضح أن
أرامكو نفسها لديها ما يزيد قليلاً عن مائتين
وثلاثة وستين مليار برميل كل منها
تركز على نجاح باهر أنها لم ترسم ، لكن من
المدهش بعد حوالي 30 عامًا أنك
تمكنت من تجديد احتياطياتك ولم
تلاحظ انخفاضًا  أمر غير عادي
بالنسبة لأكبر مصدر في العالم ،
يجب أن أجعلك تشعر بالراحة حيال
المضي قدمًا كشركة عامة ، وهو
ما استغرق ما يقرب من عامين للقيام
بالتدقيق  الاحتياطيات من قبل dnm.
تريليون دولار في المملكة الكثير من العمل
الذي تم إنجازه بواسطة المدققين الآن
والذي كان جزءًا منه عندما تحدثت
عن إعداد الشركة التي تم
الانتهاء منها في الوقت المحدد الآن ، فإنه يظهر
التميز التشغيلي الموجود
داخل الشركة عملية الحوكمة لدينا
عندما  فيما يتعلق بحجز هذه
الاحتياطيات ، فإن امتياز
ممارسات إدارتنا على أساس سنوي
لأن الله يعلم عدد السنوات
التي كنا
نحملها ونخبر الجميع
بأننا نستبدل كل برميل قمنا بإنتاجه من النفط
مقابل الغاز قمنا باستبداله كل مليون  وحدة حرارية بريطانية
وأضفها إليها وتسعة بالمائة
بالضبط والآن أظهرنا من خلال
مدقق حسابات مستقلين أن كل
هذه الأرقام دقيقة وأكثر من
ذلك بقليل  نحن قلقون بشأن ذروة الطلب
على النفط التي ستصل إلى حوالي 110 120 مليون
برميل يوميًا من حوالي مائة
مليون اليوم إذا أجريت هذه
المحادثة معك في غضون عشر سنوات ،
فهل تقترح أن ذروة الطلب ستحصل
عليه وسيسود منتجو الشرق الأوسط
بسبب أدنى مستوى  منتجي التكلفة
مثل أرامكو لا أرى طلبًا كبيرًا
يحدث في غضون عشر سنوات أو حتى بحلول عام
2044 ، سيستمر النمو في
الطلب على النفط كجزء من مزيج الطاقة
حيث ستنخفض النسبة المئوية ولكن
بالأرقام المطلقة ستزيد
عامًا بعد عام لأسباب مختلفة ولا أتوقع
حدوث ذلك بالطبع
نحن المنتجين الأقل تكلفة
وسيأتي البرميل الأخير من المنطقة